ils m'ont appelé et ils m'ont informé que
je devais continuer mon
travail et
pour autant que je sache,
ils prévoient de venir à Kaboul
dans les prochains jours, certains d'entre eux sont
déjà là mais certains vont venir
dans les prochains jours
reviennent rapidement à la normale
et bien sûr il y a certaines zones
comme l'aéroport et certaines ambassades dans
les environs aériens qui font l'objet
de beaucoup de confusion et d'hystérie et aussi
certaines personnes attendent de
quitter le pays à part que les choses
sont
normales  dans les rues et sur les marchés
et la semaine prochaine, les
choses vont probablement encore changer
parce que les routes s'ouvriront, les
frontières s'ouvriront
et cela affectera les prix et le
marché
reviendra à la normale, c'est l'
attente que les
deux parties doivent maîtriser  avec la
réalité, les
choses ne seront plus les mêmes
qu'au cours des 20 dernières années,
certaines choses doivent changer pour le
mieux
et, naturellement, les talibans devront également comprendre la
réalité que l'
afghanistan n'est pas  ce n'est pas le même afghanistan
d'il y a 20 ans qui
donnait confiance gagner de la confiance
permettant à la société de procéder
dans les limites de l'état de droit
et aussi l'état de droit doit être
objectif
donc c'est une période très très
éprouvante devant nous qui attend
nous tous et
ce sera un nouveau test pour la nation
d'
émerger en
tant que nation plus déterminée en tant que nation plus
sage
et cela dépendra du leadership